ladies and gentlemen I'd like to welcome
you to today's webinar entitled
innovation after the crisis my name is
Paul market and I'm the deputy director
for the Stanford center for professional
development our center part of
Stanford's School of Engineering
provides a lifelong education for
engineers technology managers and
executives in government and in industry
we believe strongly that lifelong
learning is critical to sustaining a
competitive advantage and whatever you
do from being an individual contributor
to sitting at the executive ranks and we
are sponsoring today's webinar our goal
is to bring you these occasional
webinars where we feature faculty
content in the latest concepts and
topics that we believe a relevant to
industry at the end of the webinar I
will also tell you a little bit about
how you might join Stanford for some
design thinking education now we move to
today's speakers professor bill Barnett
is a consulting assistant professor of
mechanical engineering and currently the
executive director of the design program
here at Stanford University he manages
the undergraduate and graduate program
and that is in design at Stanford which
is a joint program between mechanical
engineering and the art department he
received his BS and ms and product
design at Stanford and his work
profession on a wide variety of projects
ranging from award-winning Apple
portable computers so the original
hasbro star wars action figures and he
tells me that those are now collectors
items he holds a number of mechanical
and design patents and design awards for
a variety of products including the
first true slate computer it'll be
interesting because Apple comes out with
their release apparently today and so
bill has undoubtedly something to say to
those guys in addition to his duties
here at Stanford he has served as a
board member of d2m a product design
consultancy dolphin energy an
alternative energy company focused on
developing bio my biomass gasification
energy systems for salt small scale
municipalities and he advises several
internet startup companies on design
strategy bill welcome to the program
next we have Stan biker Spanish
executive director of the Center for
automated research at Stanford cars cars
is dedicated to re-envision automobile
the automobile and so as program manager
spends responsibilities span taking care
of the program strategic direction
resource management internal and
external communications and since the
spring 2009 he's been lecturing at
Stanford and in class titled the future
of the automobile the goal of that
course is to educate students and
introduce interdisciplinary automotive
thinking and to get students involved
with the industry as early on as
possible before joining Stanford spin
used to work at the BMW group for more
than 13 years between 1995 and 2008 he
pursued responsibilities in technology
scouting innovation management systems
design in series development he
primarily applied his expertise to
chassis and powertrain projects which
also provided him with a foundation in
insights into the industry's processes
and best practices he has also worked in
the three major automotive and
Technology locations Germany Detroit and
believe it or not here in the Silicon
Valley where many of the organizations
like BMW and Mercedes and VW have
engineering and research labs gentleman
want to thank you both for joining us
today for the next 45 minutes or so
we'll be hearing about how design
thinking has influenced both of the
faculty members and with that I'd like
to turn it over to Bill Burnett bill
thanks a lot Paul the subject today is
innovation after the crisis and
certainly the last 24 months have been
fairly chaotic and difficult time for
most companies in his speech to
shareholders in the 2009 General
Electric annual meeting Jeff and Mel
made this statement sort of a startling
statement that there's a sort of
fundamental reset to business and
capitalism
after this crash and whether you call it
a crash or the great recession or just
the difficulties or the last 24 months
one of our assumptions going into this
webinar today is that everyone's
organization has been affected whether
severely if you're in the financial
sectors or just increase the difficulty
of operating under these tensions on
certain conditions we're assuming if
you're here you've felt the crisis and
you're finding it probably difficult to
navigate your way forward probably you
may see your organization in some of
these questions going to think about
these questions this isn't a poll but I
just want to sort of set set the stage
for what we're talking about do you find
yourself your organization with fewer
resources now than before the crisis are
you being challenged to implement more
projects in spite of this you may have
downsized you may have a major
organization smaller and leaner but the
markets and management are demanding
more of you are your markets under
attacks from competitors may be foreign
competitors and lower cost structure or
are or from people are actually giving
away your products for free I don't know
how many of your organizations have
started using a product from Google
called Google Docs but eventually it's
microsoft office on the web for nothing
hard to compete when people are giving
your core products away for nothing with
different business models one of the
things that comes up for us too because
we hang around with the Millennials all
the time we're sort of in the business
of educating 18 to 26 27 year olds are
you having trouble understanding and
motivating me some please they're very
different breed of kids who grew up with
the internet always in their lives who
multitask regularly and who have very
different motivations and overall are
you having trouble sort of formulating
strategies in these uncertain times hard
to predict what's coming coming up and
certainly given the resources
and the constraints that you face now
maybe some of these questions resonate
with you and that's sort of the subject
we'd like to talk about today obviously
the answer to these questions is
critical navigating this crisis and
figuring out how you're going to do
short-term tactics and long-term
strategies really impacts the
survivability of your business and if
Jeff and melt is right and some of the
other business thinkers and leaders
who've written on the subject this is
the new normal we're not going back to
the way it was prior to the crash and if
that's the case you know strategic plans
need to refresh your current tactics
which may or may not be as effective as
they were previously need to be relooked
at and people are starting to look for
new approaches in this sort of resource
shy reality one of the things that
people have been talking about then a
lot is people suggesting maybe design or
some kind of design process is the
answer everybody wishes they had a
designer CEO like Steve Jobs and you
know everybody gets excited about the
kinds of innovations that a company like
Apple does but our you know lots of
people are talking about this crews nest
bomb was a Business Week contributor and
a prolific writer on the subject of
design thinking innovation creativity
you know he's saying that companies that
embrace this kind of thinking of a
bottom line edge the recent Harvard
Business Review january-february edition
was all about reinventing strategy using
design and innovation as a core Roger
Martin's one of the guys who's written a
lot about this he's got a new book out
called the design of business how design
thinking creates a competitive advantage
and Roger is the Dean of the business
school the Rotman School of Management
University of Toronto a very thoughtful
book has recommended highly Tim Brown
CEO and president of I do one of the
premier innovation and design consulting
businesses in the world has written a
book called change by design full of
really interesting case studies on how
impact strategy in organizations and
their panic one of our professors
written a book called wired to care
about sort of co-creation empathy user
centered design practices and how they
impact companies like BMW and
harley-davidson in creating strategy
certainly the lots of the popular press
Fast Company Forbes wired all sorts of
interest in the idea that somehow the
tools that designers use can be taken
out of the design studio and applied to
strategy so let's look at what the case
for that is certainly this decide as if
design is the only business process out
there there's lots and lots of ways in
which companies compete you know
everybody probably through this last 24
months has been looking at what is their
core competencies what do they need to
save in the organization as they get
leaner and what can they outsource I
think most most organizations have been
through that exercise certainly the the
wave of quality processes like total
quality management Six Sigma have been
embedded in corporations since the 90s
and the last decade people have been
working hard to make the organization
lean and efficient and anybody who
survived the recent crisis in the last
24 months have certainly demonstrated
the proficiency at managing these
processes and probably most of your
organizations have got as much
efficiency out of slimming down focusing
on competencies Six Sigma and the other
kinds of analytic business processes
that are in the current so business tool
kit and thinking so being good at these
processes doesn't necessarily different
use differentiate you strategically one
of the one of those let's just go back
to looking at a basic idea of what is
strategy you know this is a strategic
thinking equation so the classic
equation out of most strategy books
Michael Porter and and folks from the
business schools there's a very simple
equation it says value creation
up with ideas plus value capture
learning how to move those ideas to
markets effectively equals a strategy a
competitive sustainable advantage if you
can do this better than your competitors
you have a strong strategic position
well if you look at what I just talked
about the just-in-time reengineering Six
Sigma techniques these are all about
value capture assuming you got a great
idea how do you take it to a market
efficiently have your manufacturer to
lower costs how do you segment your
markets and address key market shares in
a way that gives you an advantage but
assuming everybody has already done that
or assuming that you you've got
processes in place you're looking for an
additional boost to your strategic
portfolio people are starting to say
okay where are those good does good
ideas coming from where is that radical
apple tablet in our product mix or where
is that financial product that nobody
else has how are we coming up with these
ideas and so they're starting to look at
value creation and that's where design
comes into play because it's really the
one business discipline and it is a
discipline if practiced properly where
the sole concern is increasing the value
of the firm through creativity and
innovation and finding those you know
white spaces in the market and design
thinking which is just using the tools
that designers have perfected for
inventing products and services that
those same tools can be applied to
strategic thinking and we believe if
they become a core competency of the
company then the company is more immune
to the rapidly changing markets and
aggressive competitors because they are
out creating them on the value side of
this equation another thing is there
sort of a design thinking twist to this
equation value creation value capture we
really talk about that as problem
finding and problem solving I want you
to just think back to the last five or
six projects you worked on in your
organization and how much of the time
did you spend in solving a problem
somebody's you know you got a market
share problem you've got a manufacturing
issue you've got a cost issue
you've got a competitive strategy issue
most people spend all of their time
assuming that the problem they've been
given is the correct one and trying to
solve it but there's a really a lot of
leverage and this process comes from
looking at the problem finding part
there's an old adage a problem well
defined as half solved and what we find
is that most people get an enormous
amount of leverage by moving up the food
chain in this equation and really
looking at the problem finding aspects
of design thinking so to make it a
little more explicit design thinking is
a method of finding good problems before
it's anything else it's about looking at
what are you actually trying to solve
and not working on symptoms but working
on core root problems and then it's a
method of framing solutions so that they
have a wider application and can be more
innovative and forming those solutions
in a way that's different from the
traditional methods using analytic or
deductive reasoning as I think he relies
more on synthesis and remind relies more
on the ideas that you find and the
context in which you find them so it's
not a data reduction technique it's
actually a method of putting things
together rather than breaking them apart
it employs creativity and many many
tools to enhance the number of ideas
that you're choosing from it in place
empathy which is an interesting concept
in and of itself in the next webinar I
will go into it more deeply but but
basically empathy is a sort of a deep
dive into what the you know the context
of the problem is really all about we as
prototyping and lots of iteration we're
multidisciplinary by definition and it
requires a form of teamwork which we
call radical collaboration and it's
particularly powerful when you're
dealing with the kinds of problems that
I think most people are dealing with
nowadays and their organizations
problems that are defined as I would say
poorly bounded if you use an engineering
term or if you use the term a wicked
problem that's an idea that came out of
some guys at Berkeley a while back which
you know problems that just are messy
you
can't define all the constituents who
interact with the problem as you try to
solve the problem more constituents
become visible these are the sorts of
problems where there isn't a right or
wrong answer but there's a better and
worse answer and most strategic problems
fit this category and the problem we see
more often than not is people trying to
use analytic techniques which assumes
you could know all the boundary
conditions you can know all the inputs
and then and then rationally you could
solve the problem they try to use those
techniques and problems that just don't
deal to that kind of an approach and
since designers kind of do this magical
thing where they invent something out of
nothing they're quite comfortable with
problems that have to add boundary
conditions and no right or wrong answer
nobody can tell you that they want an
ipod or an iphone they they can only
tell you they want one after they seen
one so how do you get to the thing when
you don't know what it is that people
want well that's the techniques that
designers use to invent products and you
can use the same techniques for strategy
we've been doing this for a while um
just a little a little commercial here
for the Stanford gang you know but 50
years ago 1963 we put together a program
which was crazy in his day was engineers
talking to artists and and psychologists
and and you know looking at how
creativity really starts we've started
this new d.school thing which is sort of
at the forefront of trends to blend
design thinking and strategy business
and human you know human factors human
values and David Kelly is the founder
the d.school also one of the core senior
professor in our program and the guy who
started found it ideal so the company i
talked about previously this is quoted
as saying in a couple of different
articles that the next generation of
innovators and leaders you need to be
great design thinkers and we think
there's not only design thinkers
obviously you're not going to throw away
your rationale and and business methods
for managing large organizations but if
you add in designs inc we've got an
extra strategic
but it also is is really a dynamic
approach to problem solving we still do
a lot of problem solving in design it
works particularly well in these poorly
bounded problems we use prototyping and
I'll show you a sort of a process
diagram in a second it'll kind of make
that more explicit and we use
prototyping in a couple ways one is just
to do rapid learning and improvement
you've probably heard the expression you
know fail early fail often we like to we
like to do a lot of that in fact it's a
really it's more of a fail early to
succeed sooner kind of strategy but it
recognizes that when you don't have all
the answers you built to think you don't
try to rationalize your way through the
problem you build to think it's also you
know as I mentioned an approach to
problem finding the highest leverage we
find in most of these strategic
conundrums or dilemmas is really
stepping back and trying to reframe the
issue and in that reframing and using
the tools I'll show you one in a second
you often avoid the solving symptoms and
looking at finding the real true latent
issues or Layton needs inside a problem
I also think that this creates a kind of
a new perspective it changes the way
organizations look at value creation
because it's a human-centered
perspective with the basis of all
strategic problems or market problems or
product problems there's a human being
somewhere and if you involve the human
being and a human-centered coke creation
process and you focus on the actual real
needs and up the symptoms you create a
different value for all the stakeholders
in the organization and you get a
tremendous buy-in from your customers
for suppliers and other people in the
value chain so I mentioned we have a
process everybody's got a little process
diagram it wouldn't be a PowerPoint
presentation if you didn't have some
boxes with arrows here's one its really
fairly simple right we start with
observation depending on what the
problem is depending on whether we're
looking at a business issue a strategic
product issue product line issue new
competitors entering the market I was at
CES a couple of weeks ago there's about
15 companies who have introduced tablet
computers desperately hoping to get some
kind of buzz going and in fact it's all
going to start tomorrow when Kevin apple
introduces its first tablet
interestingly enough I was standing in
the CES booth lent an ex-student of mine
on the memory for students showed up in
the booth he was the original Newton
project manager a long long time ago he
left Apple for some other things he came
he showed up in the booth where all the
tablets were and i said hi Michael how
are you and he said finest where you now
he says when i'm back at apple's and i
said let can only be one reason for that
and so I think you're going to see a
really interesting announcement tomorrow
any way you look at this you start with
observation you know you say what is
actually the you know that Layton need
the root cause of what's going on here
your information will be incomplete so
instead of trying to analyze further you
build something you build a prototype
you do a quick evaluation back with
users and with with the design group on
with that with that prototype means and
then you do it again an iteration is a
box here in this to process diagram to
make sure that you understand repetition
is is critical to the process you're
going to collapse the boundary
conditions you're going to find out more
about the process by moving through a
set of iterative prototypes eventually
you create some out plate now that's
that end of itself is not particularly a
radical notion but it occurs in a
context it occurs in a context of
radical collaboration if you're let's
say you're trying to design a new
financial service if your city of
actually a a service that was designed
by our friends at I do many of our
students are now ideal employees was the
change back program where you check
something on a credit card and they
rounded up to the nearest number and
then you end up saving that amount of
money so you can design a service this
way you can design
this way you can design a strategy to
say but it requires getting outside of
the group think of one part of your
organization now I'm here at Stanford
University universities you can't find a
more siloed place than universities
there's the Department of Engineering is
different in the department of computer
science which is different in the
department of humanities and on and on
and on and we live in these little silos
but we've managed to find ways to break
those silos down and have computer
scientists talking to psychologists
talking to cultural anthropologists
working with designers to great projects
that are exciting and different radical
collaboration is the process that we
employ to make this design iteration
work if you bring in people from
completely different points of view on
the problem you're going to end up with
a much richer set of solutions but even
then you need one more thing and that's
you need to train that team just
throwing experts from different
disciplines together on some kind of a
task force often just results in people
hardening their own ideas and their own
points of view and then arguing from
those points of view what you need to do
is train the team and two things what we
call fluency and flexibility flexibility
is about having many many problems
solving strategies available to you the
old the old expression when all you've
got is a hammer every problem looks like
a nail is even more true and you have a
radical collaboration you've got a
psychologist you only wants to do tests
and you've got an engineer who only
wants to do equations you've got a
cultural anthropologist who just wants
to do fieldwork so you've got you got to
get these people actually together
working with common tools and with lots
and lots of problem-solving techniques
and we teach lots of these you probably
do brainstorming in your organization's
you might do idea mapping we also do
morphological analysis analogic thinking
biomimicry we have lots and lots of ways
of stimulating new tools and a big bag
of tools so that people don't get stuck
so flexibility is
many many tools many problem-solving
techniques that the team has been
trained on influency is the ease with
which they use any one of these tools
and how quickly they can move back and
forth so the context the two context
dependent variables to make the make the
process work is you got to have radical
collaboration between people who are
experts in their different fields but
you've got to train them to be flexible
in fluent and then you run them through
a process of observation built to think
and you end up with you know finally an
output of a form of a service of product
a strategy a thing for me getting in
this case it's just the final details of
how the thing is implemented so that's a
that's a sort of a in a in a very quick
summary the way that this design
thinking sort of process works let me
show you one of the frameworks that we
use a lot and it's really an innovation
we call it I call it an innovations
framework and it's a classic a little
two-by-two you've got two axes the now
whatever you're making now your current
offerings your current strategy in the
future where you'd like to find new
opportunities and you've got the
concrete on the vertical axis into the
abstract and what we find is that most
teams are kind of stuck in the box
everybody talks about you know out of
the box thinking well what is the box
the box is really just sitting down in
the concrete now we've got a current
product or service we've got a current
tactic or strategy that we're using it's
it's not working well or we want to
change it and so we are down in the
concrete now when we're dealing with the
tyranny of the immediate over the the
issues that we really should be thinking
about and we get stuck doing iterative
problem solving and we come up with one
or two ideas that are a little bit
better than what we had but they
certainly aren't groundbreaking or brand
new and and it's pretty common to be in
this situation there's enough a lot of
fitness as i said the tyranny of the
immediate lots of demands quarterly
earnings resource shortages all the
things we talked about in the very first
slide so people get stuck down in the
Fox we'd suggest that you really want to
have it all four quadrants of this
diagram and and what you should be doing
rather than trying to invent in the
concrete now it's just do observations
observe clearly about what the issue of
problem well defined as half salt to
take your observations and you move up
into the abstract but still current now
you say okay what I mean when I really
look at these observations what does
that mean what kind of insights can I
get from that what sort of synthesis can
I do of that and then when you move from
that quadrant into the quadrant to the
abstract future and you go abstract
future first you're saying you're
actually asking yourself the question
given those insights what's the best
possible future product future outcome
that i can predict so i take my insights
and i I just I just forced myself to
conceptualize those insights in the
future and then I drop down into the
future now which is really the white
space the blue ocean place that I want
to be and that's where I come up with
lots and lots of new opportunity so let
me give you it's a little bit of an
abstract idea so let me give you a very
simple description and this one is
happens to be a product of one of our a
product idea that one of our students
has and it's got a wonderful outcome so
I can use it as an example but it's
quite simple so let's say and this
student was you know looking for a
project to do and he was a basketball
player and a little bit of a amateur
athlete and he had a pair of chuck
taylor converse sneakers that he really
loved and he said i want to invent a new
shoelace fairly prosaic things i meant
new shoelaces now one thing you could do
is you could look at shoelaces and the
converse you know Chuck Taylors were the
first guys to do sort of flat shoe laces
and people are pretty you know picky
about how they laced their their
converse sneakers there Chuck Taylors
and so you could have just said I'm
going to do you know if there's white
and black shoe laces i'm going to do red
and green and blue and purple and that
would be a very simple set of line
extension going from
the concrete now into the concrete now
but what he doesn't said was step back
and say I'm just going to look at people
I'm just going to add two playgrounds
I'm going to go into the city I'm going
to go all over the high school search
and look at how people wear their tennis
shoes and what they do with their
shoelaces and he did a whole bunch of
observations probably you know 40 or 50
hours of observation about how people
tie the shoes essentially but the
simplest thing you could imagine but he
came some very interesting observations
then he went up into the abstract now he
said you know what people are doing
today sir tying their shoes and the way
they've had issues just kind of a
fashion statement and in fact the the
innovation is all in how they express
themselves through the way they this
user said and the customers are doing
the innovation they're finding ways to
tie shoes them differently and he also
noticed that most of the really
interesting stuff the real cool trends
were coming out of inner-city high
schools where the kids were inventing
new ways to wear their shoes as a means
of expressing something about themselves
so we zoomed that observation into the
future and came up with a framework and
some design principles that says one
fashion emerges in the inner city too
it's all about attitude it's all about
context and three that the game the name
of the game is fastening the name of the
game is not shoelace per se drop that
down and did a brainstorm came up with
dozens and dozens of new ways to fashion
shoes has invented a thing that is not a
lease it is not a velcro it is something
completely different license just just
signed a licensing deal with converse
which is why I'm telling this story to
launch this new product it's essentially
an us to describe it other than it's
like a rubber band but completely
different and it allows mass
customization everybody can have a
different shoe everybody can have a
different style and to prove that it
would work in order to kind of get it in
a converse and sell it to a big company
that's you know doesn't necessarily by
ideas from the outside he credit ected
himself built a built a bunch of them
and launched it in some urban markets in
San Francisco and in LA and it became an
underground phenomenon and you know kids
and playgrounds just started adopting it
radically and quickly and that's what
convinced conversed it was there there
so I mean that's a simple product
example reinventing the shoelace you
wouldn't have been able to come up with
the ideas he came up with in the number
of ideas without in playing the tools we
use in the creativity techniques for use
you could do the same thing and it's
just an example to how you go through
all four quadrants of this diagram with
almost any kind of a service of product
strategy or even you know a
manufacturing process so Phylly that's a
that was that's an example if you have
questions you can I believe text them or
put them in the Q&A window and we'll see
if we can get to some of those as we go
forward with the program now I'd like to
turn things over to my colleagues fan
biker who has got an interesting case
study on some stuff we're doing on the
future of the car wellbut thanks a lot
for this little intro and hello to
everyone open this webinar and again my
name is Len biker I'm the executive
director of the Center for Automotive
Research at Stanford very nicely the
acronym it's just cars and obviously
this is what we are talking about here
quite a bit cars automobiles what's the
future of the automobile what you see on
this slide here is basically a
collection of snapshots what we are
doing and obviously and there are always
people involved they're always cost
involved sometimes there's a victory
sometimes there's just a little ideation
on a whiteboard and basically what all
this is about we put in the little
preamble that is and at the bottom of
this slide and I actually like to read
it to you and it might sound very
familiar to you compared to maybe other
statement and so that you might find in
your own organization but then
afterwards I just like to explain it a
little bit more and you might see
hopefully you will see how we apply a
lot of the design thinking that bill
explain to you how we explain actually
do something like the automotive
research so the Center for Automotive
Research at Stanford will shape the
future of the automobile through
collaboration of academia and industry
for unprecedented levels of safety
performance sustainability and enjoyment
so I think two very important things
here one is really collaboration of
academia industry and for sure it just
does not make sense if we wanted to work
on automobiles at the University just by
ourselves obviously we're not going to
produce automobiles obviously and we
need automobiles in order to work on
them so we definitely need to team up
with the industry but also the notion
obviously the automotive world has
really seen major disruption over the
past two maybe three maybe five years
whatever you want to name it and the
notion there is that the industry is
actually seeking to get input from new
places such as maybe in university in
Silicon Valley which is not necessarily
known to be historically the first place
for automotive research but so here we
were the center at Stanford and the
other thing that I really wanted to
highlight in this preamble especially
the last line the bottom line we are
talking about safety we're talking about
performers we are talking about
sustainability that's probably not very
surprising period to any of you this is
just basically the buzzwords of the
automotive industry at the moment but we
definitely want to focus on enjoyment as
well because we just say you know what
if we just look at green and clean and
in face that certainly great and very
important but in the end the end product
the automobile is fierce so much more
than just a clean green and sort of
thing it's actually a very emotional
thing and people want to enjoy this and
there was the realization so far about
our vision statement so and who are we
and what are we it's actually an
automotive research can
at Stanford we are bringing together
different types of laps of student
groups of department and that has been
working traditionally and traditionally
here in that case means 10-15 years on
automotive target and we basically
combine them bring them together and try
to strengthen the community and the
other part that we have is an affiliate
program that we work together with the
industry that I mentioned already to you
and that is maybe a good point where i
can actually share a little bit of the
of the inside and the experience that I
took here I've been here no for about
one and a half years before that I think
at pawn mentioned it in his eventual I
used to be a BMW and when I started to I
expected really a culture shock so
everyone's home okay you're going to go
to the average house going to go through
the University and you will really be in
culture shock well the shock actually
was there was no culture shock and so
the the organization as a university was
actually very similar to what I was used
to from that case the automotive
industry because there are so many
processes they are very different
departments a lot of forms assembly
rotisserie there are some hierarchy and
will do also mention earlier in his
presentation that it actually can be a
pretty siloed organization and so our
main task here with this kind of
automotive research actually how do we
break this up and how do we actually
make people collaborate what we have so
nicely pointed out in our vision
statement and I wanted to show this to
you in one example which you see only
excuse me there was a little bit too
fast there we go on this slide and how
do how do we do this how do we break up
this silo thinking how do we actually
help people to collaborate and the most
important thing is really there need to
be a solicitor and it's in a way it is
my role in my team so we really help
people to identify the problems that
they should work on together what bill
also pointed out SB problem finding and
here we have just three key questions
can a computer drives better than
human can you combine diesel and
gasoline can texting and driving be
friends obviously three question
statements from the computer science
department from the mechanical
engineering department and from the
communications department and this just
happened to be our four founders from
the faculty side so three professors who
really go together and and then the
question was ok and Kenny computer drive
the car better than human well why do
you want to do this why do you want to
do all this autonomous driving that you
might have heard of it I've been going
on here it's definitely worth it for
quite some time and then there's all
this while texting while driving just
don't do it but well let's just say that
people are doing it and then so we
started off with the problem definition
so what can we do and this is what you
see in this little picture there on the
top left we really got together with
students and then this read the very
important pieces students from all these
different departments they bring in
their creative thinking their experience
as a consumer essentially some of them
might be texting while driving even if
they don't omit and to be said well what
can we do and then we went second little
picture here we're going to prototype in
what bill also pointed out in simulation
virtual reality so how can we control
the car so that the driver gets more
assistance while driving actually we can
lower the workload on the driver and
then and the third picture they are
creating a lot of dust making a lot of
noise there is also the fun part and the
enjoyment that we mentioned little
earlier in our vision statement and
prototyping in the real world and then
the end product would you see here is
this white car basically racing
autonomously on the salt flats and in
utah and so all of this sounds pretty
much like unbounded activities what we
mentioned earlier so how do we all bring
this together we actually have a little
teaser prepared for you it's a little
video that we wanted to share with you
that it really shows how these four
steps would just explain to you the top
the problem definition the prototyping
in the simulation and virtual reality
prototyping the real world and then the
end product how we did this and
therefore we want to show one minute
video to really highlight these steps
and showing the excitement and all of
this and you might want to turn up the
volume on your computers because that
makes the experience even a little bit
more visual and audible
alright everyone so I hope that this
broad across pride excitement that we
had during this project and it's
certainly going on some of you might
have heard about this project the next
step is actually to raise alternative
autonomously at Pikes Peak in Colorado
and and what we also talked on this is
really great collaboration that we have
here between academia and industry which
is really key key to make all this
happen and the next slide I just wanted
to introduce our automotive program to
you a little bit more who we are and
who's collaborating and and also talk to
you a little bit about the challenges
that we have and basically what you see
here is a logo of all the different
entities that we have on campus and off
campus and the corporate logos currently
we're working together with five
automotive companies and they support
our program and they are part of the
projects that you just saw for instance
in this little video and but you are our
on campus partners and let's just start
here and and then at the top which is
the dynamic design lab there's a lot of
automotive controls going on what we
mentioned earlier with combustion
engines and also via dynamic control
woody just saw on this video so that's
going on there and certainly then the
next little red circle here the
artificial intelligence lab where a lot
of robotics being applied to the
automobile and things may be that you
expected where you say well okay
autonomous cars well did it all nice so
sure don't you see robotics and
controlled but we're also working very
closely together with constantly in the
business school and the law school and
interactive media groups because and
going back to the mission statement that
I showed you earlier it's not about
safety only it's not about
sustainability own it's also about the
enjoyment people are paying money to
actually do want to spend money on their
cars because if they just want to get
from A to B maybe a $15,000 car would be
enough but it just turns out that the
average sales price of an automobile
still is 27 thousand dollars and
obviously still the second largest
investment the people are making during
their lives but certainly a very good
idea to speak to the folks at the
business school and to discuss where all
this is going in order to entertain
questions like well it's still a status
symbol order more like a personal
statement that an automobile and if in
society and and also the the last right
the last red circle in the on last chime
lab which is a communication of humans
and interactive media so all these
things how do you discuss with your car
or something a bit wacky but if you
think about it I mean a navigation
system in an automobile you actually
communicate with this system it actually
speaks to you sometimes you yell back
you just realize it doesn't work but
just rest assured people are working on
these things all you're going to have an
argument with your car certainly in a
way that it's supporting you and ever
getting from A to B and that all the
rest assured that the enjoyment we are
definitely working on this to keep this
up all these different entities this is
what we have this is who we are and I
definitely want to mention and it has
been hard and it does not always work
out and so there's one more aspect that
we are going to add to this we will have
a brand new building only for automotive
research where we bring together all
these people because we just realized
even a campus such as Stanford which
might be about the size that a large
corporation always had also has but it
just so happens even if you adjust to
blood stone and the road on campus
people just have a hard time finding
time to meet so we will have a building
where people really run into each other
where they collaborate on things where
they just always crazy ideas and have a
chat about this over coffee so we also
realize that this is very very important
the disclosing will be up in a few weeks
and we are definitely looking forward to
working on even more safety performance
sustainability and enjoyment of the
automobile it's a little bit of a case
study there was a little bit fast but I
hope you took away from it some very
exciting things will be due here
automotive white and Silicon Valley I
guess what this I gave it back to Pauls
for the wrap-up of this session today
Thank You Sven now if you have questions
please do send them in via the chat tool
the Q&A tool we have a number in the
queue and they're very good we'll be
staying throughout to answer those so if
you have questions please send them
whether it's about design thinking in
the front of some of the frameworks at
bills cash drawer for cars my
responsibility now is to let you know
how you can engage further with either
cars or with the concepts of design
thinking that you heard earlier the
scent Stanford center for professional
development delivers education to
industry we do so through graduate
programs and professional education our
goal is as I mentioned earlier to
deliver lifelong education wherever you
are in your career and wherever you are
in the world our focus in particular is
to highlight a course that's coming up
jun 16 to 18 as we've talked with
companies we noticed that as bill
mentioned in his framework the focus has
been on a concrete and now and what we
believe is that innovation is something
that needs to be sustained and nurtured
in every organization so we have framed
got some of the best thinkers at
Stanford to develop an executive
education course here on jun 16 to 18
later this year it'll be a three days
hands-on workshop we hope you bring your
teams and you're really challenging
problems whether it's designing a new
service to capitalize on some data that
you've identified or whether it's to to
morph a new strategy that will capture a
larger market share so we're excited to
have this and if you have any questions
about this program I'm your contact you
can see my content information down
there as well here's a quick outline of
really who should attend as I mentioned
this is really for senior leaders who
are interested in learning more about
design thinking about how to extend that
through your organization's and how to
build a framework it's no longer the
domain of the lone genius sitting in the
back room we believe that design
thinking can be taught at that it can be
learned
they become a valuable tool of
communication as you're dealing with
customers with new ideas and even with
those who are really trying to look to
turn around things yes you need to focus
on the concrete here and now but it's
also important to understand your
customers to do more observation and to
bring those ideas to concrete future
opportunities the key program takeaways
are really exploring in depth some of
the methods you'll really learn how to
build and nurture within your own
organizations the notion of us Bill
suggested radical collaboration and we
believe that this idea of prototyping is
a really important way to drive
innovations now and in the future of
your organization some of the key
faculty are highlighted here I want to
mention that in particular a few of the
faculty have been around quite a long
time not quite as long as the 50 years
at Stanford has been just developing and
delivering education around design
thinking but some pretty close and we
also have a number of young faculty
Chris Gertie's as as identified in the
lower left is leading the cars at
Stanford so a quick polling slide here I
wanted to get your gauge your level of
interest in this design thinking course
you know we we have a dis offering it's
the first time we do hope that you might
be able to join us you and perhaps your
jeans or share it with your colleagues
so the selections on the left are
definitely interested but I'm ready to
go interested that i'm not sure i'd like
a little bit more information not sure I
want more information or the course is
not right for me at this time so I'm
going to let a few more registrations
hit and I'm gonna
see right here and we'll close those
poles and appreciate your your you can
see that there if some selections want
to let you know that if you have any
more information excuse me if you need
more information please contact me the
innovation master series will be an
annual event so we hope this is the
first of many we also appreciate your
feedback and letting us know if we can
bring other things our next for the
design innovation master series our next
webinar will be on Tuesday februari 23rd
at 9am it will feature bill burnett and
a band of energy effect remember
mechanical engineering and director of
the design program and they'll be
discussing design thinking a competitive
advantage in a difficult economy if
you'd like to a copy of today's
presentation of the slides please print
it on door download them from live
meeting now in the upper right hand area
we welcome inquiries and follow-ups if
you have anything to add or our errors
that we missed there were many good
questions in the queue we have a couple
of still remaining and we'll be in the
room until those questions are all
answered we appreciate you taking time
to join us today we know your time is
valuable and with that we conclude
today's webinar we thank you very much
and have a good day